zum ersten mal spricht alpa gun wirklich
ausführlich über seinen leider gestörtes
verhältnis zu sido hintergrund ist der
track zu diesem thema ist raus alles war
die sekte und auch bei seinem verhältnis
zu bushido hat sich was geändert darüber
spricht er auch in einem der nächsten
videos also abonnieren nicht vergessen
und jetzt viel spaß mit alpa gun
gesamtprogramm
meine frage
immer schätze silber freuen
devries die lage genau die muss ich ja
ja ja ich weiß jetzt was soll ich da
noch
das hast du gelernt dass ein text
gelernt ja wie ist die lage
die lage ist frisch alles cool
viel zu tun ja und kein
bier haben leider kein bild mehr am
lager für mich endlich aber gerade
herausgekommen das video ads alles war
die sekte alles war die 6
und da da geht es ja um nichts anderes
als um brief oder nein sondern hast du
dir schon angehört ja ganz ehrlich
gestanden
naja du sagst zumindest dass das alles
nicht so toll war ich sage fakten sowie
es war möglich weil die fakten wird er
wahrscheinlich anders anders sehen das
ding ist ich sage mal ganz von vorn land
ist es kein biss wenn ich wissen würde
dann würde es ganz anders aussehen ich
sage halt nur die wahrheit was da
zwischen uns
ich würde gerne sagen was dazwischen es
gelaufen ist aber es ist nichts gelaufen
weil es war keine sekte es geht ja nur
um die sekte
und ich meine kannst du auch die
künstler oder die wepper selber fragen
noch alles cool aber mit wem von denen
habe ich telefoniert oder mal ne frage
wie geht's was machst du heute oder
morgen wird es im studio nein das war
alles immer so wir haben uns dann vom
trecker treck getroffen und wann haben
wir mal einen track zusammen gemacht da
wo wir einen sektor album gemacht haben
oder wenn sie nummer 1 album gemacht hat
dann haben wir's mal getroffen um eine
64 und damit ich mich mal richtig
getroffen da ist immer jeder der zeit
hatte oder je nachdem wie derzeit das
ist ein studio gegangen hat seine strafe
aufgenommen und wieder nach hause dann
ist der nächste an einen anderen tag
gekommen weißt du das war so ein
durchschauen zwar keine sekte zwar keine
gänge und
ich meine wenn man auch so sieht ich bin
ein junge von der straße vielleicht
genau wie die aber ich werde ich bin
ganz wo anders aufgewachsen nicht da wo
sie aufgewachsen sind es ist halt ein
riesen unterschied für mich gewesen nur
sido
gegenüber weil ich sie loyal war er war
mein freund weiß sie doch hat gesagt
kommst du in die sekte machst du deine
musik da weiter ja dann habe ich gesagt
okay dann komme ich den sieg machten
musik weiter aber es war halt keine
gäste das habe ich dann halt in dem song
erklärt und klar gemacht wie es wirklich
war
wobei sie dort bei uns im interview
gesagt im ersten interview was für ein
super verhältnis er zu seinen freunden
hat wie er die unterstützt
seid ihr das nicht gewesen man als
andere leute die er gemeint hat oder
wenn ich will wissen wen er damit meint
jemand von einer sekte soll man zu mir
kommen und sagen sie du hast mir in
meiner karriere unterstützt ja ich immer
wenn wir mal studie zusammen saßen habe
ich von vorn oder vom band gehört ja ich
habe kein geld wenn du musst den knast
weil er schulden hat sie dann muss sie
dann nur die schulden bezahlen damit
daraus kommt finden das ist freundschaft
das ist für mich keine freundschaft
warum muss der junge knast kommen weißt
du warum muss der ersten klasse kommen
weil er schulden hat ist doch schon
peinlich genug in dem alter wegen
schulden ins glas zu kommen warum
funktioniert es bei den nicht okay band
war auch vielleicht mit zeitplan oder
ein oder der andere hat sie eine zeit
lang ein bisschen faul und hat nichts
gemacht weil sie keine zukunft gesehen
haben ja keiner hat diesen leuten die
jungs motiviert wenn sie dies aber genug
beschäftigt mit zeit kam schön und gut
aber dann kümmert euch dort um dann
besorgt doch jemanden der sich um die
sekte kann man irgendein manager was
kostet so ein manager ich bitte dich du
musst immer noch voraus nächsten
bezahlen wenn die sekte was wenn die
einnahmen kommen durch die sec oder
seine prozente oder wie auch immer je
nachdem ob er wirklich arbeit geleistet
aber das ding war jederzeit linke sido
bobby sie wird natürlich ein bobby
mitgezogen ich meine wer war denn bei
aggro berlin nur die beiden weißt du wie
du war das zugpferd und wie war der
mitläufer
aber was ist mit dem rest der gang und
das habe ich klar gemacht in dem song es
war für mich keine sektor und sie du
erzählt in seinen interviews mal wie
alles schien gut ist aber es war nicht
so und warum kommt sie nicht zu mir als
freund wie waren jahrelang befreundet
warum können wir nicht bei uns warum
muss die kamera gucken und klar ja ich
bin froh ich habe kontakt zu alpa gun
sein management warum zu meinem
management wurden nicht mit mir selber
früher haben wir doch auch direkten
kontakt gehabt und das fand ich halt
schade auch die jungs ich mein ich will
jetzt keine namen nennen aber ich bin
offen wo man
toleriert mich er sagt ja du hast du
sagst war es recht nicht es ist ein
ehrlicher und ich musste sagen einfach
der öffentlichkeit klar machen dass es
nicht so aussieht wie sie du das immer
rüber bringt das war mir sehr wichtig
und deswegen musste ich diesen fang
machen ich wenn sie doch auch monate
lang hinterher gelaufen ich habe ihn
angerufen kam keine antwort schauen sehr
an reporter gesprochen kam keine antwort
ich hab versucht seine mama anzurufen
damit sich über sie vielleicht kontakt
riege kam auch genannt wird statt das
sieht vielleicht manchmal als ältere
frau anruft und sagt komm mal her mein
junge nach hause wie früher meist kommen
wir einmal junge nach hause lasst uns
darüber reden was ist euer problem ich
will dass sie kein problem aber weil ich
mag den schweiß aus den guten geschmack
ich kann mir vorstellen dass sie jetzt
ein bisschen enttäuscht es von der
aktion aber ich bin auch enttäuscht ich
bin auch ein mensch irgendwo hat es mir
auch weh getan weißt du ich könnte jetzt
echt weinen weil ich finde dass die
leute von mir falsch denken und ich bin
auch so alt genug ist auch alt genug ist
nicht jemanden in berlin ich kann den
leuten sperren wie lange gab es hier
sagte sie sich einfach die sekte
liebsten nach seit einer ewigkeit schon
seit zehn oder wie lang war sie dabei
ich war jetzt ganz ehrlich ich glaube
2005 habe ich dann sage ich mal fünf
mitgemacht seitdem bin ich halt auch
intensiv entscheidend dabei ich glaube
seit 2006 2007 als sekte und bis heute
war das für mich keine siebter aber als
du da drin das hast du doch weil
empfunden
ganz ehrlich auch nicht auch nicht auch
nicht wahrheit gesagt ich war sido ja
und ich fand es halt ich mein ich bin
nicht so auf sie ich bin auch keineswegs
umgang war überhaupt nicht aber das war
bislang auch so bin ich nicht ich bin
enttäuscht dass er mich ein
riesenunterschied so bin ich auf
jemanden der mich die ganze zeit ärgert
weißt du sido hat mich vielleicht nicht
geärgert aber ich bin enttäuscht ich
mein ich habe wie soll ich sagen ich
schaffe es selber zum beispiel kennt
manager jetzt abgesehen von der sekte
ich selber um karriere gemacht ich meine
2007 ausländer heute gibt es wetter
draußen die haben ausländer krass
gefeiert das dorf ein nasa das hat mir
in mein gesicht gesagt dass er ausländer
gefeiert hat weißt du und hier noch mal
schöne grüße anna sei dank für seinen
respekt rechte aber das ist für mich
natürlich eine ehre dass mich jemand
sofort zu als mit meinem debüt album als
ein junge von der straße der zum ersten
mal am 8 ich habe einfach heute einfach
meine gefühle loswerden mehr resse und
das hat bei mir funktioniert mit der
musik aber warum haben es nicht auf die
reihe gekriegt hat es schon auf tour
gehen ja das war so was von menschen
warum hat mich keinen persönlichen
management auf einen manager gehabt der
sich um mich kümmern sie wird kann sich
nicht gekümmert er hat genug zu tun
bobby hätte er hat ein bisschen was
versucht aber er ist auch nicht der typ
dafür dass ein künstler irgendwas
ausschreiben und machen warum macht ihr
euch keinen kopf darüber das ist bei mir
wie es funktioniert und deswegen habe
ich das gefühl habe und was mich
vielleicht ein bisschen nach meer gehört
wenn ich jetzt zurückblicke habe ich das
gefühl ich war kein künstler von sido
ich war sein beschützer ich habe die
ganze straße ferngehalten sie bekam ich
einmal mit einem droh sms und so zu mir
hat neben immer schon vorgelegt wird ist
nämlich klären man sieht es auch bei one
love festival
interview mit
und was passiert er unterbricht mein
internet sagt er sagt man wer es leute
nicht da ja natürlich einfluss auf die
auf kollegen
und da fühle ich mich natürlich auch ein
bisschen verarscht die adresse wo ist
die freundschaft und wenn er zum
beispiel ein album mit bushido macht mit
einem erzfeind ja denn
die ist jahrelang von sido ferngehalten
habe weil ich bin auch gut mit seinen
leuten wir sind eigentlich im inneren
gerne auf der straße man kennt sich und
ich habe immer von ihm fernhalten mit
meinen freunden und ich habe diese macht
auch in berlin weiß ich habe damals
schon eine straße nicht kenne die leute
ich habe die politik ist kann mit dem
reden reste werden positiv geklärt nicht
mit streit und beef aber das wäre noch
schlimmer wenn ich nicht dabei wäre wenn
meine freundin nicht dabei werden aber
warum wenn es während der zeit schon
erfunden hast warum heißt es dann
gemacht aber leicht zu loyal bin ich bin
zu lassen dann muss man sich ich wollte
ja klar man muss es aber ich bin halt
der junge wirklich der junge der von
herzen erfreut ist für sie da ist und es
ist eine ehrensache vermissen weil ich
wenn sie bei problemen mit denen und den
hat dann hat automatisch ein problem
auch wenn ich vielleicht mit den kunden
und den hallo sagen aber wenn er sie du
bist dann habe ich ein problem mit ihnen
sollen sich fernhalten er soll offen da
man sonst hat ein problem mit mir und
dann gibt es auch - wenn es sein muss
aber wer er eigentlich ist es doch was
gutes dass ich bushido und sido das was
gut ist natürlich darauf komme ich jetzt
auch und was mich an der sache geld ja
wie gesagt als die droh sms ohne diese
probleme von der straße fernhalten von
sido ja aber wenn sie dann zb sich mit
bushido versöhnen will ich meine ich bin
kein mensch der sie doch was verbieten
kann oder der sido sagte finde ich es
nicht gut aber ich finde das echt gut
und cool oder wenigstens das mindeste
was er tun müsste das aber zu mir kommt
und mit mir nix eine minute darüber
redet oder ich weiß du hast all die
jahre nicht vor diesen leuten beschützt
wir haben meine mutter beleidigt die
haben auch text meine freundin
vergewaltigt der meine mutter jackie
genannt so richtig ehren lose sachen
heißt und da habe ich wohl verdient ja
das ist einmal zu mir kommt und sagt wie
findest du das wollen wie das so alles
machen hinzu was dagegen ich würde
natürlich sagen sie danke für deinen
respekt dass du mit deinem
respekt zeigt und mich noch mal darüber
nach oben nochmal darüber bericht ist
also mich nochmal fragt ja
dann wäre alles wm mutter wenn wir alles
easy ich hätte nichts dagegen und das
album was er mit ihnen gemacht hatten
das zeigt mir dann natürlich wieder das
ist nicht wirklich um die versöhnung um
die menschen um das menschliche geht
sondern nur ums geld geht ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass die beiden
privaten zusammen mal abhängig machen
das ist machen sich das weiß ich es ging
halt in ihrem swissness und das kriegt
mich natürlich wieder wofür haben wir
all die jahre gekämpft und getan und
gemacht weil ich da habe ich echt
verdient dass er immer zu mir kommt und
mit mir geredet und ich musste die ganze
scheiße von der straße von den leuten
erfahren sie wie viele machen alle böden
sind cool ist sagt er glaube ich nicht
ich habe alle dinge wie hier in den raps
hier nicht nur gegen die dogan und ich
habe meinen blieb auch alle fast wieder
ausgebildet ich bin zu assad persönlich
gekannt habe ihm meinen respekt erwiesen
und hat gesagt
das war nicht unser bestand für sie
ruhig werden ist doch normal ist für
mich eine ehre für meine freunde da zu
sein und eigentlich war das ist unser
buch ich möchte mich erzählen damit noch
einmal entschuldigen bei den und so
haben wir alles aus der welt geschaffen
oder geschafft
und das ist so eine sache mit sieht und
warum er nicht zu mir kommen mit mir
darüber redet und ich musste von anderen
leuten auf der strasse erfahrung wenig
spricht sich alles schnell rum
aufgestoßen aber warum ist das so also
ich habe jetzt schon mit vielen rappern
interviews geführt also auf der einen
seite wird von ehre von
freundschaft treue loyalität all diesen
dingen gesprochen aber es gibt immer
wieder dieses der einwand die ganzen
super spruch im deutschen heißt pack
schlägt sich pack verträgt sich also
immer dieses hin und her aber warum wird
es so hoch warum braucht man dass ich
alles auf kleinerer flamme oder muss das
sein aber ich sag mal so
für viele ist diese dieses dieses web
diese
diese web schiene ist es sind hab das
ist ein hartes spiel ressel man verdient
nicht das was man so denkt so westen und
viele von diesen rappern versuchen durch
versuchen schneller an ihr ziel zu
kommen und dann schießen sie auf ihre
ehe das ist mal lose züge weißt du ich
habe das gesehen auf unser von felt und
vor feinden also erstmal mit denen ein
feature machen zum beispiel sich
anziehen und dann als hemmi gehen und
dann
zu ihm rüber zu sido und presse das ist
für mich keine das ist für mich keine
realität was da geht es halt nur ums
games business sie wollen alles
versuchen so schnell wie möglich hoch zu
kommen und dass die leute die hören
möchte das war für mich das war für mich
echt eine serbische schaffte ich es
nicht machen ich wollte so sido ja die
ganze zeit ja ich hätte auch auf ihn
schießen und auch mein ding bei den
anderen versuchen aber wie soll ich so
rüberkommt ehren los einfach aber hand
aufs herz aber kann man das ding ist
hand aufs herz hast du immer alles
richtig gemacht kommen das will ich auch
sagen jeder mensch macht den film ja ich
bin auch nicht perfekt vielleicht sehe
ich meine finger nicht vielleicht habe
ich auch viel sagen ja aber ich sag mal
jeder mensch macht einen fehler aber das
was er gemacht hat das war in los für
mich ist das ehren los die zeigt dass
ich für ihn da stehe ja für ihn da bin
ich bin auf der straße mit sido gewesen
ich bin ich habe ihnen gefahren ja auf
der straße und ich weiß wie berlin tickt
ja ich habe jeden tag damit gerechnet
dass jemand mit seinem messer an komm
und sieh du angst machen will oder sie
abziehen wollen oder in opfern die
hätten noch mister opferten schöneberg
da hat er mir auch zu danken und ich
habe immer damit gerechnet dass ich als
erster auf die fresse fliege das stellt
der erste stich kassiert und ich habe
auch stich klassifizierung ob für
bushido oder für sie du das war egal ich
habe diese straße am oberkörper und ich
wäre beinahe gestorben was ist das
passieren es war ein kopflos an unserem
auftritt auch vor sieben jahren dabei
bushido sido ich wäre wie waren alle auf
tour auf einen auftritt in cottbus
zusammen noch zusammen ja
bei allen zeiten und
wir haben
dann kamst du auseinandersetzen der
maschine irgendwelchen anderen richtige
nazis nachgewiesen müsse und ich
natürlich wäre ein neuer freundlich geht
dazwischen
und was passiert es eskaliert und ich
will als erster offen wer ist alles
abbauen sind alle abgeholt und ich bin
so ich bin kein feigling keine angst ich
habe versucht mir zu helfen anstatt das
an erster stelle mai nachdenken sagt nun
wissen und da habe ich natürlich den
oberkörper stetig kassiert und das war
auch natürlich war natürlich schade für
meine eltern heute denke ich lieber gehe
ich lieber solle lieber seine mutter und
sein vater rhein anstatt mein vater
meine mutter reste und sagt auch wenn
ich dann also finde ich wofür ich war
als ich dann dieses bild de von sido und
bushido wie sich um arbeit im echo das
heißt kriegen schon mal ist ja nicht mal
ihr verdienst aspekten das video gedreht
aspekt nach sowieso ein krasser künstler
an der hinsicht erst einmal kasse videos
ist es entbrennt ich weiß gar nicht wo
ich habe deutlich freut mich immer aber
anstatt dieses bild zu sehen ja
wäre ich lieber am dienstag weil sie
sich in der stichwahl gestorben habe ich
schon gedacht in dem moment das hat mich
echt gemacht
wenn du jetzt zurück bringt ist das dann
verlorene zeit oder was denkst du dir
weil du hast ja auch weil er hat sich ja
auch was entwickelt also es gibt ja die
beiden punkte die eigentlich müsstest du
ja dankbar sein wenn ich habe bereits
enttäuscht ja dank mal wenn ich auf
jeden fall ich habe auch ich habe
erfahrungen mitgenommen schaut mein
talent entdeckt ich habe sogar noch
schauspielkarriere rechte
schauspieltalent habe ich auch entdeckt
ich habe viel gelernt auch an der zeit
ich wollte das hat mich auch natürlich
von der straße weg genommen ich habe
früher gras gezielte ich habe so mein
geld gemacht du bist doch an so besuchen
sie das ist mein schicksal das ist mein
schicksal einfach rest aber erst am ende
nur schade warum das alles so enden
musste heißt das dass ich enttäuscht bin
am ende und sie trotzdem ein ding machen
das hat das tut schon weh aber
auf jeden fall haben sich positiv und
negatives mitgenommen wirst du es willst
du dich jetzt ein bisschen wurzellos
dadurch dass du quasi auch um diese dass
es diese gemeinschaft letztlich nie gab
der oder für dich oder ich
war früher auch mal ein einzel gingen
auf der straße und ich kann auch alles
alleine durch die wir zum beispiel und
ich merke selber seitdem ich es von den
weg bin es bewegt sich viel mehr
menschen im internet ich habe interviews
sich viele interviews kommen radio ich
habe mich aktoren autogrammstunde sagen
wir uns alles selber er aber das heißt
du glaubst dass es jetzt mit ehrensache
besser läuft als vorher viel besser viel
besser rechte und da kann man es braucht
stolz darauf sein dass man selber auf
die beine kriegen und schade natürlich
warum es damals nicht funktioniert hat
mit einem hitler ausländer naja ich hab
natur jetzt übrigens finde leute da
draußen ab erster sechster bin ich auf
tour weißt du wie deutschland ich bin in
münchen ich bin in braunschweig ich bin
in osnabrück ich bin in hamburg ich bin
in
stuttgart nämlich
ich bin in 80 städten bin ich auf jeden
fall farbort bin ich auch in wien bin
ich super das habe ich alles selber hin
bekommen haben habe ich das damals nicht
geschafft worden warum hat es nicht
funktioniert jeder zweite war danach mir
draußen kommen ist auf tour gegangen
hatte auftritt ich hatte nicht mal
einzelne gigs wie traurig wie traurig
und wann natürlich verdient man nix was
verdienst vom album verkauft wovon hast
du dann gelebt ich hab mal ganz ehrlich
ich habe viel investiert viel gemacht
ich habe einen partner er ist ein könig
erst einfach kind erlebt der türkei
kommt er lebt von renten aber zu teuer
ist wie millionäre wie laufen auf schnee
und hinterlassen keine spur ich habe
immobilien in der türkei sie leben gut
ich kann die auch sehen was ich alles
sagen aber ich will nicht angeben es so
gehen gibt ja auch kein problem mit der
steuer und das alles geklärt man das
alles ist so eine sache wenn ich für
mein album vor schluss kriege oder was
verdiene dann mache ich das natürlich
schaue ich weiß deutschland bleibt ist
nicht so wie in amerika dass ich da
millionen verdienen müsste also
investiere ich mein geld schlau und
versuche daraus ein bisschen mehr zu
machen also gesicht dieses geschäft
nicht in diesem geschäftsfeld habe ich
schon von der straße name ist und ich
musste auch nochmals hassen und auf
jeden fall schon achten müssen und das
ist auch etwas was ich wirklich
mitgenommen aber denn da gibt es auch
der spruch jeder tropfen öl getränkter
ich will wirst du es denn dann auch so
machen wie du es von anderen erwartet
das tut sich ehrenvoll immer verhalten
oder ist es das geld das dann den
charakter vielleicht verbirgt
geld natürlich ist so ein großer punkt
der den charakter aber ich sag mal so
ich suche meine freunde so aus ich sage
zu meinen freunden ich bin so so so zu
dir ich mach dass du das für dich und
ich würde das finde ich auch tun und
dasselbe verlange ich auch von dir ich
sag's vor nach irgendwas in der länge
hat die ehrenvolle ding was du keine
loyalität ja stolz
und ehre respekt respekt ist auch ein
richtig wichtiger punkt ist dass zum
beispiel wenn man hinter meinem rücken
wieder mit den anderen einer kulisse
ohne mich jetzt und ist auch respektlos
weißt du dann verlange ich von dir wenn
du von mir was falsches gemacht das hat
auch ein älterer bruder gesagt er hat
sich richtig schön gesagt wenn du von
mir was falsches isst dann kannst du
kommt mein koffer packen aber wenn ich
von dir das falsche sehe dann hat sich
der kopf hat er habe ich das recht den
kopf abzuhacken und dann siehst du was
der gemacht entweder er kommt die
nächsten tage erst einmal für dich da
und sieht es eine machst du das
verhalten von ihm verlangt und
christlicher im größten land und das
will ich da oder du siehst was für ein
falscher das ist ja kein bock auf so was
ergibt erst mal eine hand am nächsten
tag siehst du denn drüben auf der
anderen straßenseite sagte hallo und am
nächsten tag darauf läuft auf der
anderen seite war ich nicht kenne weiß
ich dann weiß ich zuerst gefreut okay er
kann das nicht durchziehen meine freunde
sind so dass wir das wusste sind jetzt
eine richtig gute partie und jetzt könnt
ihr euch immer die wahrheit ins gesicht
sagen ohne wahrheit geht sowieso nicht
möchte ich hab mal zum beispiel mein
freund resümiert wenn ich zum beispiel
ein neben ihm telefoniere und mein
freund nicht
verletzen will und sagen und lügen
belügen gerade ich mache noten ich sagte
ich habe gerade zu tun und so und so da
sagt man folgt resümiert bruder sei
ehrlich sind einfach hinten auch wenn es
eine notlüge ist da ehrlich damit man
dich so sieht und dich besser einschätzt
weißt du er sieht da er sagt du sagst
die wahrheit weil du zu tun hast und es
war für mich an dem tag auch eine lehre
dann habe ich den jungen gleich alles
schon gehabt sich angeboten ich wollte
dich dass du jetzt gekriegt bist aber
ich bin jetzt also ich hab ganz fertig
muss erst mal sagen ich kann jetzt nicht
zu dir kommen möchte das ist für mich
eine freunde wie auch hinter deinem
rücken für dich ins feuer springt das
ist für mich ein freund das filmische
qualität und das habe ich gerade und ich
verlasse mich hundertprozentig auf meine
freunde und ich weiß jeder einzelne
freundlich jetzt gerade ist sollte
niemals diesen rufen deren musik machen
wir sie nach all diesen ich meine schon
32 31 für 32 mit 16 sind wir ein
bisschen erwachsen geworden werden wir
erwarten mit 20 eine dort mit fünf bis
fünfzehn bis noch ein jugendlicher von
15 bis 21 jahre sechs jahre bist du
kannst neue freunde kennen ich hab mit
21 7 grad bis 31 10 jahre die meiste
zeit meines lebens habe ich mit ihm
verbracht nach verlange ich ein bisschen
respekt das ist ein bisschen respekt das
hat für mich kommt mir die sache klären
und die zum beispiel der schwarm
freunden
das sagen alle dass er mir nicht
verzeihen würde lasse sich das
öffentlich gemacht haben was soll ich
machen ich rede hinterher so steht er in
auf tour ich will mit den letzten
auftritten kommt nicht mal eine minute
sagst du nicht nur dass wir darüber
reden du kommst aus dem register com zum
kochen wie sagt man du gehst ja der
konfrontation hast du aus dem weg weißt
du das ist was da bin ich ein fremder
für mich geht es dir so gut ist
geblendet von deinem erfolgt oder ein
bisschen so vernebelt von drogen lässt
und das ist das ist für mich ehren los
respektlos dafür habe ich nicht meine
zeit nicht mehr erwartet aber ich habe
aus dieser zeit gemerkt und deswegen
kann ich jetzt auch mein freund besser
aussuchen
und kann mir alles viel besser machen es
in der zukunft und gibt ein schrecklich
ich habe sie nun diesen leuten habe ich
damals immer ich habe es versucht ich
habe zehn mal mehr mühe gegeben dass die
von mir nicht stecken wie die leute auf
einer straße weil viele von unseren
jugendlichen waren der erst mal ein
lächeln ins gesicht
deswegen ihr ein gesicht und dann fick
mich nicht von mitnehmen und ich wollte
dass sie nicht das gefühl von mir ich
habe seine mama angerufen habe gefordert
wenn irgendwas braucht ruft mich an ich
komme und
so von herzen ja nicht nur um eine
romantische habe ich so oft angerufen
meine mutter ist kalt du hast gerade
gesagt du bist nicht in alles
war die sekte aber ist dann so was was
ehrlich gemeint ist nicht viel schlimmer
als und ist daher ist halt nicht besser
zu wissen und sich wieder zu vertragen
quasi im rap business design ist das
ding warum so ruhmreichen presse ich
will den leuten da draußen nichts
vormachen richtig wollte kränkt als ich
im internet lesen musste kommen hier
nicht vor die augen von seiner mutter
oder seine schwester verrät bist bist du
ich bin kein verräter ich hätte dann von
der mutter verlangt dass sie mich in
ruhe sagt komm lass mir über alles reden
was ist tatsächlich passieren weißt du
das kränkt nicht wo zuweilen die jahre
dafür dass ich will gar nicht rum
häuschen ich bin ein ehrlicher mensch so
hat so wird es von meinem vater erzogen
ich bin wirklich ehrlich auch wenn ich
ab und zu noch noten wie gesagt dann ist
auch möglich im juli aber sonst bin
nicht so ehrlich wie möglich und das
sind fakten die jeder da draußen wissen
sollte jeder einzelne jeder mensch da
draußen muss muss wirklich nicht einen
mitmachen bei uns keiner so denken das
licht der verräter bin also ich bin
meiner linie immer treu geblieben
ich war immer loyal und übertragung des
wichtigste ist dass wir selber wenn die
kinder krank sind an zu wachsen damit
machen wie wird es gibt es irgendeine
möglichkeit normal dass er ihnen wird
das enden wird das wird kann man die
möglichkeit geben dass er zusammen kommt
oder wieder euch
vertrag
ja man kann nie wissen was die zukunft
bringt
man kann über alles reden ich meine
gucken was die zeit bringt also jetzt
müssen dort enttäuscht wenn wirklich
sido sich meldet und sagt hey lass mal
darüber nochmal reden dann würde ich
vielleicht habe ich auch fehler gemacht
ich bin mein fehler hin sind weil er
seinen fehler einsieht dass ich finde er
hat den fehler gemacht dass ich mir
darüber drehen oder diese ganze
geschichte worüber wir jetzt gerade
geredet haben feste oder mit meiner
karriere dass selbst ist nunmehr kopf
machen müssen über mich so wirklich kopf
über ihn gemacht habe also man kann über
alles reden ich war ja an befreundet war
sind auch viele sachen die er für mich
getan hat und ich finde haben und hätten
wir die sachen brauchen auch nicht reden
was interessiert und was an auf jeden
fall ist nicht so dass sein haus gingen
aber es tut weh deswegen muss sagt wenig
machen ist aber man kann die listen
erwähnten nur gott verzeiht ihm den job
wer sind wir denn dass wir uns diesen
stress ist ein witz also ich wünsche
euch dass ihr euch vertrag vielleicht
nicht dieses jahr vielleicht nächstes
jahr oder irgendwann mal das ist ja
schon schade wenn man zehn jahre lang
das miteinander zu tun haben wir uns
sehr eng dass man dann irgendwie das
tischtuch zerrissen ist und was ich dir
noch wünsche ist ein riesenerfolg für
ehrensache das ist mein ehrensache
und wenn er noch mehr zum thema sehen
wollt dann empfehle ich euch den track
mit sido in dem er darüber erzählt wie
er mit freunden umgeht und auch nicht
uninteressant ist der talk mit kay one
da geht es auch um den umgang mit
menschen und er erzählt dass er white
stance also die beteiligten weiblichen
personen gerne mitten in der nacht vor
die tür setzt also bis dann bleibt dran